[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello-o everyone low I didn't see you
there fan links welcome I was reading a
book I didn't know we were streaming
today I guess I didn't know you could
dream boy oh boy well welcome to our
little game Ozone's watch party we
really appreciate you guys taking some
time out of your really busy days to
squeeze a little time and for some game
as owns watching first I guess we're
gonna tell you a little bit about
ourselves and in our background and
we'll answer some of the burning
questions and then we'll dive into some
some content Craig get in the zone
so I'm Craig I'm the younger brother and
I'm Adam and I'm the youngest brother
now I'm just kidding I'm Craig I'm older
than Craig yeah pretty old we've been
asked if we're twins but we're 6 years
apart I even created gamma zones six
years ago was it yeah we started in 2014
and game bosons is a weird cartoon
because it started off as just like a
stupid little mashup that we made and
then it got really popular and we kept
making more and that it just became a
series we like evolved it into a series
and that's a lot of it's weird evolution
is why nothing makes sense in the
universe yeah so it was originally
supposed to just be like a pseudo
trailer for like a show called game of
zones and we're gonna show little
vignettes from around the world and our
universe it was actually originally
supposed to be about the NFL and we
changed that because it was the NBA
Finals were coming up so we made it
about the NBA and we were here yeah
sorry Craig sorry guys we have delay
we've also never used the internet
before
so like when we animate we don't even
use computers we just stand back and we
just tell people we say make his head
move make his arm moves this is our
first time on a computer and so you know
that that explains some of the technical
difficulties we don't know much about
the streaming culture so pardon our
rawness yeah we're we're Millennials
were not gens II so we're really not
with it but I will tell you this before
so Adam and I so before I started
working with Adam Adam had made two
videos out of his apartment
that one was sports friends it was
actually called basketball friends at
the time and another one was called game
of cones and it was about I had another
one and another one was a movie called
Shawshank Redemption which is not true
that that's what I was like so we just
want to we're just show you the two
carts like clips from those cartoons
that we sort of what game of zones was
born from so first we'll show you a game
of cones which is an icy version of
sorry Adam what yeah I'll just say this
is like game of zones mom and dad you
might think that game is ones' mom and
dad is the NBA and Game of Thrones but
actually it's game of cones and
basketball friends they came together
like the children of the forest and Game
of Thrones and they brought us this
wonderful world okay why don't we show a
little clip of game of cones now roll
the tapes oh my sweet sama treat what do
you know about fear fear is in the
winter when it's so cold freezer burn
it is in that darkness I scream walk
that deep and dogs came for the first
time is it true that he saw a dippin
dots I don't know what he saw are you
saying he's crazy afraid not son I'm
saying he's pistachio there's been
disturbing reports
what kinda reports fruity fruity creamy
ones we've been captured fro you
enjoying it
oh they were enjoying it continue but I
mean I was enjoying it see the influence
there for ya game of zones before we had
mashed up Game of Thrones with
basketball Adam had matched up Game of
Thrones with ice cream because he liked
ice cream a lot yeah basically in the
way that idea was I was like the way I
came up with that idea I was like what
doesn't exist right now that needs to
exist like I really want to do something
to make the world a better place and so
I spent a week or maybe more than that
probably three weeks making ice cream
cones Game of Thrones yeah so if you
guys if you wanna watch the rest of it
you just search it on YouTube it's
somewhere out there the other thing that
was the let's call this the father of
game of zones was sports friends and we
have a clip for you from basketball
which is a sub brand of sports friends
am gonna explain a little bit yeah so so
sports friends was a show that we did
for two seasons on Yahoo screen rest in
peace Yahoo screen it doesn't exist
anymore around no no if Yahoo does
either
but but if I'm producing is there and
before that it was a thing called like
first was baseball friends which was
just Chase Utley and Ryan Howard talking
about how much they loved hitting home
runs and you can check that out on
YouTube or Montcalm and then we after a
couple baseball friends I made a
basketball friends with LeBron and
Dwayne Wade and it was
when he had just signed with the heat
and so that that gives you a sense of
when it was and that those those were
the samples that went on to become the
show sports friend so this is the
original sports friends basketball
friends and our first foray into
basketball animated contents roll it
okay
he's a great guy in fact I like our
whole team like you're on one's really
cool or on like high the heat is on the
heat is on stop it puts me in a bad mood
that instantly puts me in a bad mood
LeBron he's a great guy in fact I like
our whole team sorry
so it seems like we're getting some
feedback from the booth but a lot of
people want to know why game zones is
ending so why don't we talk about that
I'm sure that's something we'll have to
address a lot we're gonna cover this and
then we'll get into the episodes and
then was like um I feel like that's a
that's a hot topic so there's a few
reasons but I think the main reason one
thing that people OTT of people think
bleach report cancelled game of zones
and that's not true
bleach report certainly would want more
gamers owns like they loved it and we
love it and and and there's nothing
there's nothing there it's more that
Craig and I at this point have done
about now we're you know it's our
seventh season and it takes all these we
take these things incredibly seriously
and we like they know how to make we've
earned about fifty thousand medieval
basketball jokes in this property right
yeah and and it's just it's just that we
want to try something different
and now the game of Thrones is done and
also I think that there's like it's
there a lot of things go on too long a
lot of shows go on too long and we
didn't want to be a show that became an
old joke we wanted to make something
that was really good and fun and then
I had to find a nice way to end it with
that when it felt appropriate so it
wasn't just going on too long and this
felt like the time for us now that being
said there might be some game there
might be some Game of Thrones game as
owns in the future but for now we just
we want to try some other projects
anyway
work now I hope that answer served to
your knowledge cravings let's jump into
the episodes now and we're and just to
give you a quick heads-up before these
episodes start this this is the first
season we're gonna watch the very early
game of zones and one thing that's
really some things that are really
interesting to look for is look how the
heads change the style changed and and
and look at notice how different it is
when it's was when it started to what it
is now yeah the episodes were much more
literal like we took Game of Thrones
scenes and just did them as
straightforward as game of zone scenes
and pretty as the seasons go on we kind
of diverge from Game of Thrones a little
bit more and developed our own lore and
you know some people are upset about
that but at the end of the day like
you'll see like we run into a lot of
problems like logic problems in terms of
matching characters up we have like
several Jon Snow's by like episode 3 and
so ok anyway we'll start showing the
others in role yeah let's start playing
it because people people have seen it
people have seen it so we can talk over
there's a lot of really good questions
coming in and so I want to answer the
questions and I feel like if people if
you really want to watch these and hear
them in everything like that you can
watch them all on YouTube but I think
what's special about is that you have us
here to talk you through it and answer
question to go there it is you can see
here there's no background artwork
that's because we didn't have a lot of
time dogs but the next you are all
nerves yeah and just you know back when
we did we did these seasons we were
doing it all by ourselves we had one
friend of mine Pat Keegan shoutout
Hokkien who did the storyboards joined
but Craig and I did everything for these
early episodes so that's why they're so
simple
that's why the characters barely moved
jool the voices grow did we edit it we
animated it everything so and we really
don't know what we're doing so not of a
miracle have a flat it's amazing I've
just changed in the NBA since this
episode came out nice tickles
yes by the way Steph Curry had done
anything again so Derrick Rose here was
our original brand we've had a few of
every character and a lot of people
thought that that Derrick Rose was Mario
Chalmers and so that made me really sad
and that's why the heads got much more
detailed is because I was like I'm never
gonna have a likeness issue again I'm
gonna get really really detailed heads
and that that was that was the genesis
of that with that Derrick Rose Mario
Chalmers mix-up of 2014 oh yeah the
scene before the fray scene was actually
really supposed to be the bus but then
we did it about the Lakers because they
get more views so here's a there's a
couple questions one is
someone says that Stephano says hey guys
I had Matt hill as a professor at UC
meet him and start working with him yeah
it's positive one second so Matt hill is
our writer he it was it's we we've we've
had a couple writers in our time and and
Matt Hills been one of them and he has
been awesome he's really great we love
meeting with Matt and and he has a
podcast called the my favorite
basketball podcast you definitely check
it out but Matt Hill is an economics
professor at UCLA so yeah you know
that's important because economics is
that plays a big role in our code also
shout-out Dan Moore who was our other
writer and he was on last season he was
great
so anyway let's and then although we
also utilize a ton of writers from
Bleacher Report so one of the nice
things opening a police report is if we
can't we're not you know we know
basketball like fans but we're not
experts we always run the episodes by
everyone we can at bleacher report
who is an NBA person so like for example
if if we're doing a Celtics episode we
talked to Celtics fans if we're doing a
Bucs episode we talk to Bucks fans you
know we're checking out the Bucs now
let's stuff so like we there's a lot of
there's a lot of writers that are more
like they're not writers but they give
us feedback and they help check out our
stuff and give us good fun facts anyway
let's keep going
while this is playing a yuning eyebrown
with they would see the mariota's our
second brand scene and Williams brand
being and sorry Derrick Rose being brand
was very popular in the first episode
and we've managed to find another scene
that worked with the Bulls next year you
know and we add Rhonda's John Snow and
that was weird choice fun Easter Egg
there on that tree that went back you
saw before there that was actually tree
Rollins so if you notice carefully can
see yeah our young sparrows
and I have a question Craig do you want
me do a question sure
No Oh sounds like he doesn't but I'm
gonna doing anyway okay so someone says
well the coronavirus disrupt the release
schedule for the final season and that
question was from Malc
and thanks Malcolm Malcolm so the answer
is no we are on track it's coming out on
April 30th this Thursday and one of the
reasons that it's on track is we have an
incredible production managers named
Chris Bollinger and he he kind of
anticipated this all happening and
helped us get set and we got all the
rain check all the animators ramose and
so we what we're on schedule we're good
to go look to have me little one yeah I
know this question how do we get the
voices Adam and I do every single voice
this game zones we will we have like a
bunch of accents that we are able to do
and we just modulate our voice so it's
like pitched lower so like for example I
am Kyle Lowry so I say what's going on
there I don't know I want to play some
basketball players that's not I don't
know and I am James Harden and I am
James Harden who has slowly we started
off as Prince Oberyn but then he became
more like triumph the insult dog at that
point and another one absolutely LeBron
but my voice is pitched down
significantly cero it wouldn't sound
like a brawn but I would be like good
people of Cleveland Thank You Holly
coming out today and I do / - you know I
know Greek wine I drink wine and what's
the other thing he does has sex with
hookers yeah yeah cuz there's two things
let's just carry drink wine and stuff
and then another voice is the Hound is
one 7l so adored like this coming up in
this episode here your battle CY Kyle
schwarber is a hawk yeah captive a hawk
and it's just commitment to making him
the bird Gary yeah like as this Joe
develops rice we were tried to
reorganize the world as we were going or
filtering the buses were driving the bus
splashes and we just like grandfather
and some things like kyle korver because
on the oxen is just always a hot Rochin
speak okay I would say one thing about
the Nuggets here which is a lot of
people say we never feature the Nuggets
excuse me
I think nuggets alert it's happening and
this right here yeah all right Craig go
ahead we may need Kenneth for a let's go
heard Steven was really or something of
this game of drunks what why are you
complaining yeah I know and there's a ty
lawson that's about 15 is automated
doesn't see was Brienne of Tarth
talking to Jamie Lannister LeBron was
Jaime Lannister earlier in the show
interest and Kevin Love number that one
seemed to adore Mormont isn't to be over
and some word was used to have a hair
like that chemistry yeah you know it
won't see kind of Harris grow in his
character
out and there's no he's no longer the
show you part of some fun Mahad Alvie he
by the way this year is a really bad
dick joke unseen oh yeah really true but
we were not allowed showing fine oh yeah
right
normal yeah if anyone wanna be glad
smile with Oh Kevin love's fun this DM
also this is the reason why James Harden
has a bizarre accent it's because he's
Oberyn Martell a whole lot of people
tuned in like later in the show and
they're like why is Martin sound like
he's Mexican do you Spanish something
and it's because we made him a Dornish
man and we just committed which is based
off and I have no regrets
yeah and also this penis based on it
being a game of Thrones where he's
killed two Lannisters or beats them up
or something in the whorehouse yeah
alright so so this is one do another
question episode ever sure let's do
another question okay so someone says
you need to rewrite for Kobe's passing
or Co vid so obviously with kovat we
were mindful that it's very very hard
for us to make last-minute changes
because as the show's grown it's a
really like this animation style is very
complicated and so it takes a long time
and and so it's very hard for us to
maneuver and react to things that's why
we chew usually our episodes are about
older stories and we kind of we can
never compete with everyone trying to be
super topical on the internet so well we
try to be as weirder and more creative
and more thoughtful and we do older
stories but it can be challenging when
things change you know if you're writing
a what a cartoon it's about like a team
being really bad and they'll sudden they
make a run before the playoffs it throws
off your joke so it's that's a risk that
we run but as far as the Kobe thing and
we'll see some Kobe stuff probably this
will come up a few times but that was
really tough obviously for a lot of
reasons most obviously like it was
really sad in general but I remember we
were actually at a game of zones meeting
we were meeting about this last season
and we were talking about Kobe and how
did what's what to do with Kobe and and
then that was like an hour before and
then all of a sudden the news came and
we couldn't even believe it and we were
just like we had to cancel them we
couldn't even think straight we had to
cancel the meeting and we just had to
figure that out and then the leadership
a police report they wanted you know us
to do some sort of tribute but the thing
about our show is like you know we don't
really react quickly and we did want to
put something quickly one to think it
through we want to do something
thoughtful and so there may or may not
be a tribute to Kobe in this final
season but you'll have to uh you have to
watch Craig anything that let's uh I
don't know anything at all time
such a delay I'm like it's hard to
bounce off so this is Derrick Rose is
going into the layer of guard 23 who is
a mysterious person who may original
child of the parce like you once way I
can yeah and roses knees were a big
topic at the time everybody perfect
a lot of you kids don't remember but
this was like this was the year of
Derrick Rose's knees and there were a
lot of these years but that was like he
and back before coronavirus this is what
everyone was talking about I was like oh
that's going on Derrick Rose's knees so
we was just low-key one of my favorite
scenes yeah
so he made a Doc Rivers dannis natural
fit he's got yeah stances his daughter
Sriman oops
yeah and we got to make him we gotta
make Austin Rivers the exact perfect
dynamic you know father-daughter
father-son go to hell you by the way
there is a question from Damon Conway
and he says I wanted to ask you the
creator's if your favorite NBA joke is
LeBrons tweet about Kevin Love fitting
out and I will say Damon no that is my
favorite NBA joke there's been a lot
maybe top 75 maybe tops um yes I put in
my top on all the jokes I mean like just
like you got to think about any like
I'll top my head right the whole junior
Smith throwing soup I mean come on so
yeah but it but it was but at the memory
we enjoy so we got a question yeah I'm
sure the wizards like once that's not
true
we showed the wizards like at least
twice they had they had a scene
in season four they had wizard hats okay
they have like the best yeah mouth fit
of anyone on the show let's get that
yeah by the way we did have a scene with
them I'm sorry go ahead
yeah Bradley Beal sent stuff in the
lottery episode so what are you talking
about also also we had Boyan I mix up
Boyan and Bogdan so forgive me but like
whichever one got traded spoil yeah the
Wizards Boyan and and he was like oh my
god that's like so many wings oh my god
it's like a so many wings so many wings
who's eating wings in the his wizards
had and the feast of these and I will
say it was a that's one of her
one-dimensional characters is Boyan
Bogdanovich who's only dimension is that
he says things that sound like oh my god
it's like so many wins yeah yeah that's
all he does one thing is that we were
gonna do a scene with the Wizards we had
it kind of mocked up but it was -
inappropriate we're like two players
from the Wizards like go down into into
a cave and they've discovered they used
to be called the bullets and they but
they don't know what bullets are in this
world so they find these met these these
guns they think our magic wants they
started going like this and they start
shooting bullets everywhere but uh that
like we were encouraged not today we got
episode be like I think Jonah's bonus
was dead or something I don't know it
was not it was somewhat no gortat so I'm
gonna board that or click that yeah the
basketball podcast we don't know
anything about basketball fun yeah oh
yeah lamer I know nothing about
basketball Adam knows a few things about
basketball and then people bleacher
report know a lot of a basketball yeah
well we know we know a lot now like I I
know a lot now I've always been I've
always played games but Craig's a little
less so though but yeah we went when we
started the show I didn't even know who
Steph Curry was and then I slowly all I
knew about basketball was exactly what
we had
yep game of zones episodes and then like
over the years I've like developed a
more rounded knowledge of basketball and
you know I have random gaps of knowledge
so like if you just said like Stephon
Marbury I'd be like who but I know I I
uh I yeah I grew up we both grew up
Sixers fan so I was like a hardcore
Sixers fan I'm a bit big I've always
been a big NBA fan but not unlike but
there's always people who just I find it
like when you when you're in the
basketball world like it feels like
everyone else knows more than you but at
this point okay have you ever considered
doing it NFL version of gaming zone so
we had we and we had a seat in the
original concept was supposed to be NFL
and we're gonna do a scene with Tom
Brady as Jamie Lannister
and Bill Belichick as Tywin and the
alignment were horses yeah Konami never
made it sorry yeah we never did that and
it became yeah it became MBA but now if
you if you want to experience animated
NFL content I recommend you check out
gridiron Heights which is run by the
incredibly talented Dennis Flynn all
right let's keep our you call the tape
player of the year and you are my son
does this mean I get to start
well that's playing I will say that uh I
am Shane black says can you do some 90s
bold stuff and I will just say to that
just maybe oh my god
and like the fight we had about who was
gonna pony as a Drake fight yeah great
break yeah we both wanted to play Drake
and so we both recorded ourselves
singing the part and we played it
anonymously for people around the office
six people actually and it was a 3-3 tie
and then I just got to do it no I think
it's because you got to be a little wait
no little way was after this before I
listened I'd let you have break because
I'm the older brother
and I always bully him it's I was like
trying to be nice so this is a second
piece of raison rondo
no wizards just already on Rondo and
brand I mean he dropped the c-word a lot
um which is totally fine in Game of
Thrones world but apparently less so in
sports no we have questions from Josh
after Shakespeare maybe and he says that
who comes up with the in-depth hidden
jokes and details
well Josh thanks for noticing and thanks
for watching
so we will brainstorm those with
ourselves you men out to some of our
experts at bleacher report and we'll
show them the backgrounds and say hey
what can we squeeze here and then and
Matt Hale and Dan or whoever else and
Evan Matthews who's
in the control room somewhere he's been
he's our producer and we will just look
carefully at the scenes and our our
attitude is you know why waste any
background like you know add that
Express really dense if you guys are
gonna be spending your time even if it's
five minutes watching something we're
not going to give you crap we're gonna
do our best even if it's a silly little
basketball cartoon to make it worth your
time and so that means like we want to
pack it with details and make sure that
the backgrounds have fun stuff and
there's like tears of watching that you
can do so we don't want to brag but good
will will will go through every phase of
production so it starts when we're
writing we think of background jokes and
things and then as we're recording it
will come up with new jokes and then
once we get the storyboards back we'll
find like places in the background and
put it and we just keep adding layers as
it goes down the assembly line of
production and by the end we've packed
as many jokes as we can because we know
that guys you know like the the people
that are watching on YouTube can pause
the screen and they can scour the
background it's not like watching
something on TV where you don't have
that control and then you can comment
about it so we started noticing people
were seeing all that stuff so we could
put those fleeting details in there
because it was gonna get seen rather
than you know assuming people were gonna
miss it all and then one thing out a
couple things from YouTube here while
this do you play this go ahead oh
there's Kobe our first appearance of
Kobe this xx he has tries to lure rage
on Rondo to the Lakers which happily
enough yeah several years alright so
pause it here we got we got a want to
get to use some YouTube questions but I
do want to have to we have to preface
this episode this is the dumbest episode
of yes the worst and the reason why this
is the dumbest episode is because this
was made for the Warriors this was made
Steve Kerr reached out he was a fan and
wanted us to do an episode for the
Warriors for their team dinner and so he
gave us a ton of inside jokes about the
team and like sums that he was with
Steve Carson nicest guy and he was like
we're like are you sure we can use some
of this stuff it was like some of those
inappropriate like you d end like like
the fact that andre igudala like grabs
his dick and like yells like hold my
dick or something like that way makes a
three-pointer or some like that and like
or like and so that's what this episode
spoiler it's going to end on but this
episode is bunch of inside jokes and it
plays you can watch it on YouTube with
the Warriors reaction reacting to what
of this video you can see the whole team
watching it Steph Curry is yeah doing on
the napkin and laughing it was it was a
real that someone and that ties into a
YouTube question which was someone asks
what's up you've had making an episode
and one moment I'll say which wasn't
necessarily fun but it was like
incredibly cringy and exciting was when
we got the video back of the Warriors
watching this episode we're going to
show you and saw them watching us doing
their voices like us voicing them it was
really uh that was crazy
that was crazy so anything else that
Greg yeah I will say I was really
frustrated because dislike completely
disrupted tool or at the time and
everyone thought this was like part of
the series but it was really supposed to
be its own set back from the rest of
game zones and I don't think people got
that so I was just trying to erase the
like memory of this once we move forward
after this episode but pretty soon is
like everything kind of fell apart but
all the characters got mashed up you
know like they were they were both
Daenerys and then there on the wall and
it was just like yeah yeah so let's go
ahead and play this one and then Craig
as it's playing I'm going to a couple
questions I'm gonna I'm gonna bring up
so one person says how long is the
process of creating an episode so I'll
let you handle that since I don't pay
attention yeah well I I want to answer
that but I think we should answer
questions maybe between episodes and we
talked about the absence for watching it
okay so yeah this so we
I'm used with the new guy yeah and then
we wanted to try to get as many guys we
could you know the Brazilian blur was
the thing about Barbosa that we could
make a joke about Bogota this is a world
leader governor we literally just gave
we just manatee yeah assistant coach
Luke yeah don't do that kid first a lot
we get Harrison Barnes dirty because he
he was always there was a clip of him
like staring at Ross gold yeah to get
what you need thing drives me crazy
that's like the most inside of inside
jokes that no one gets ever read borders
we even get Winston yeah that guy does
the Elgin is named Brandon a few members
they by the way by the way yeah
the gives me a speech about beating
their last season of 67 wins and this
was the season they had the 73 win
season or if it was p.m. we take credit
further amazing season
there's Looney and Babb who we do want
to draw their faces who you see them
from the back and then stick stance that
was like really funny to the teeth this
is my favorite part
yes oh there it is the the old pygmy
dick joke
let's go back to what that final hold my
dick part and then just I just want to
play look at the animation there and
just look how bad it is so we go add up
anything they just go from Saul
crouching to all stood straight up yes
it's like we had no time to animate and
so right here everyone just hops up it's
like a video game I'm like hey charming
okay so let's pause it for a few
questions then you know we're gonna do
our best to get you out of here before
the Jordan dock but but we're gonna stop
or answer some questions now so first
one here is Mahad Alvey says how did you
manage to animate the Nick Norris
reaction and add its the Raptors episode
so quickly so that one was when that we
had it just seems so when that happened
and that became a meme we already had
the Raptors episode basically ready to
go something like that is kind of is
easier to add because it was just that
we already had Nick nurse and we are he
was already there so we just had to give
him that mouth and just cut away to him
so that was a that you know every
problem is solved I think some problems
are more complicated than others some
things are really hard to cover but if
you can come up with a quick solution
for things and we'll talk about some of
those quick solutions as we get into
some later episodes you know it depends
on what the animation lift is and that
one was an easy one one other question
is oh who thought of putting the horse
does worse things in the series so that
I don't remember who thought of it but
the idea was that they would just we
thought it was funny when you're
parroting that that scene from Monty
Python I remember oh that's so what
happened was you were improvising Adam
was doing the voice of Frank Vogel he's
like it's a horse and then he kind of
just like it does horse things and we
thought was really funny we kept it in
the episode and then
you know I wanted to keep referencing
the horse the deer seemed Adam and me
stylistically is I like being self
referential so like stuff we've
established earlier in the show and Adam
likes to keep doing new things and I
think they're both useful perspectives
but and all I'm trying to say here is I
fought to keep the horse this horse
things in you can thank me you're
welcome
Adam had okay but fair but now we tease
tied in as you may have seen in our most
recent episode in a big way to our final
seasons so he's become yeah we shop
tomorrow deer part of the lure yeah and
then one more question we'll do here
which is let's see oh great why don't
you ask answer how long is the process
of creating an episodes I think that's
um it's in production
yeah we get this question a lot an
episode takes a back ok so the first
episode took about two and a half weeks
which is insane and Adam and I worked
really long hours all weekend long and
everything but the episode is really
simple now episodes take about eight
weeks because we actually like we've
beefed them up and we have a like we
just make it a lot nicer and that
process takes that long because we need
about two to three weeks to write and
record it and then we hand that
recording off to our storyboard artists
who will we talk with them about what we
want to see in the scene and then we'll
do some back-and-forth with them and
they'll block out all the shots and
they'll put you know the basically rough
images of what will match the audio so
where the characters will be with a
background look like then the designers
and the background artists start drawing
all the backgrounds and the characters
and then finally the animators move all
the characters around over those
backgrounds and then someone called a
compositor
they put everything together and layer
it all on top of each other and put
special effects on shout-out to Tom Lich
and then we spit it out the end and put
it on YouTube and Twitter and that's a
really really simple way of explaining
how it's made yeah so we'll come back to
more questions after we walk you through
this this Coby episode and as we play
the surf this is a this is when Coby
retired bleach report wanted us to do
something for Kobe's retirement and so
we came up with this purple retirement
which is a spoof of the purpose for the
purple wedding I think that the Joffrey
scenes actually called the purple
wedding because it's before the Lord of
what happened to him for anyone they
actually call it they might actually
call I'm not sure so one thing about
about this episode with that I'm wrong
okay so one thing that's interesting
about this episode this is the first
episode that we had a little bit of
animation helped as we hired our first
animator Brandon Fletcher and and then
we also brought in richard Silvius who
has become an incredibly integral part
of our of our team to do he did
backgrounds and things and and he does
some of the wonderful background art
that you see and he gives us a lot of
those Easter eggs that you someone had
asked a question about before certain
he's making the background he says hey
what if I did this or what if I did that
in fact one of his great ideas do the
bronze messed up seed in the big statue
so anyway that's that sorry Craig goes I
was maybe stepping on your toes there
speaking of LeBrons nice trophy yeah so
you can see Mitch Kupchak sitting in the
episode 1 yeah we just oh you know what
worn them in there
Evan make a note of frank kaminsky shoes
they're for our special VR kicked thing
right oh yeah we're trying to collect
all the fire kicks that we have in the
show yeah so uh guard 23 doesn't show up
to Kobe's party comes a little hurt and
then we have Shaq whose it is cuz this
is could exact outfit from Kazaam or
Shazam which one's the club Shazam I
think it's his album blue tipz Nick
Young and also known as swaggy P this
boy here he's the same voice as March a
toe in the water
sending do the snaps of recording
forgetting the whole clothes the whole
thing that'll yeah he yeah he recorded
Nikki I'm talking about like yeah she
knows girlfriend or some like that I
don't know and like yeah and then that
happened so we're like we got to do
something to that and we had to
brainstorm we thought of the the
inappropriate Ravens um so let's take a
puts pause right here answer a couple
more questions so let's see I want to go
back as I skip some really good
questions I think but uh let's see here
Oh so who wrote the rhymes for all the
rappers Lil Wayne Damian Lillard Dame
dalla he calls himself so that was
actually us Craig and I we we are we
love doing music stuff you should check
out if even had a chance to partic stuff
we did for police report like the poor
zinc hot wings on Broadway the ports
Angus thing and the super team warriors
musical that we did which was the follow
up the next year too we did that for the
Warriors for their dinner for the team
winner dinner but yeah for all the songs
we write all the lyrics we perform it we
did the only one we didn't was the Kobe
let it tank song that we did we we hired
Craig's friend to do that Garth Garth
Taylor greatest name yeah but anyway
yeah with all the Van Gundy in Moncks
there are there rants Damian Lillard
it's one of it's both of us who we we
take either write the original songs
where we take like versions of Game of
Thrones type songs and we and we do it
ourselves
we got another question says what do you
have any favorite deleted scenes or
scenes that didn't make the show we have
a couple deleted scenes that maybe we'll
show tomorrow because they're for season
four I believe we won't with Mark Cuban
will say we posted him on the app a
while ago
and I think they're pretty good I think
we just didn't do them because we didn't
have the production resources at the
time but they are you know anyway I'm
stale so I know that we want to
we're running short on time so I want to
keep rolling through these but I one
last question is someone asks a to
lovino s-- s why do some American
players have foreign accents and I'll
give you our roll real quick which is
that all American players have British
like Game of Thrones accents or Irish or
whatever they are like they have accents
from the show with the exception of like
Shaq and some other people Berkeley a
little bit who some people have like
they're just we love doing impressions
of them and so like we don't give that
they got anyone who has an actual accent
we give them their actual accent general
generally speaking so I'm all people who
speak English as their natural language
like they get a British accent or some
form of Game of Thrones Mieville exit
and all people who have an accent
we tried do their accent why I don't
know this no rhyme or reason it just
became that so you'll see here that
karl-anthony towns you can keep watching
them so you don't see his mouth of that
scene that allowed us to not animated
something else and that saves us time we
do a lot of little tricks like that
forever
with some animation instead of us a
Wiggins this year's Catholic this is one
of our better number one I've seen
squeeze at just to like a game of
Thrones they've kept it very consistent
we're able to do that scene I began with
games learn as Thor severe the problem
was that there's so many teams that
don't has worn championships being a
Brotherhood without banners and that's
always bothered me wait to get them in
banner but so many other things work so
well for South between yeah just like
yeah just felt like gee guys and for
Samir's
silver dime Leonard sort of like eyes on
like the
Neverland the top pop what's easy player
but like always kind of a cool guy hover
introduce these Lisbon posters this
might be my favorite joke watch what
this little segment here I remember we
search Wikipedia and were supporters for
all the play if there's anyone who ever
played great on Ruster I don't know if
we found this is back when Dwight Howard
was on the Rockies and we had made him
tell wheels lover mother of the sand
snakes okay here's where LeBron accents
to draw more models because we're yeah
Ron becomes Bora yeah yes this is also
you can see the background something he
got it was the back fence so fast
and they had the the stuff and this is a
really really people give us a lot of
credit for a good call that was a really
bad call to say that LeBron had brick
scale and that he was gonna start going
downhill because he didn't are going
down you want to pause it and see if we
have any other questions or you want to
maybe hmm let's see here we've got so
much nothing you guys gonna have a
playlist of the first video or a full
episode without commentary so yeah you
could check all that stuff out it's all
available in YouTube all those videos
are available without us being annoying
over them but uh but we're not gonna
stop by the way we got a fact check it's
the movies called Shazam not cuz I am
okay I'm sorry okay
alright he's funny behind the scenes
yeah we'll do that one next time go
alright let's go ahead and play and then
Oh Craig this is like this wasn't really
a full episodes really short she's like
one scene I think yes play it so this
was no this was a react to the big the
big loss by the Cavs to LeBron
I'm sorry the big defeat of the 3-1 Cavs
come back to beat the Warriors and this
was predicting the flight of Kevin
Durant from right whoa muffled the Cavs
Kevin's you the bay area tarp and he's
always kind of been like Brienne of
Tarth yeah Greymon data for the other
draymond did a bunch of kicked a bunch
people in the balls it doesn't matter so
yeah this was and also the year that
they had that epic series with the
Thunder and not longer an Allen and that
was the whole time he came and happened
to join them and so this was dream on
getting his comeuppance know background
detail here I made all the little
there's all these guys that back
brothers
mostly dead but they like blink once in
a while so they're actually just sitting
there like staring at the whole scene
playing out and not motivation
they're not dead kings of the wooden
comb yes he forgets people like and also
really funny I wouldn't mind all the
head coming to raw and this was the last
head that I designed was Kevin Durant
and after that we had artists who are
much more talented than me take over and
that's why you see some incredible heads
going forward what you great dream on
and Kevin Durant laughs one side Avenger
will do to you
yeah duty says do you - yeah I just do
your duty in the sort of the actual
scene reference you should watch the
scene that we base that on and then
watch that scene from game of zones and
you'll see like how closely we pair a
little bit Stannis says do your duty
before he's but at this point yeah
but and so we had dream on say you're a
duty and I really like that joke for
people that know the scene that we were
referencing it's a pretty good one I
also so I believe that is the last
episode we're gonna watch tonight so
we're gonna answer a few more questions
squeeze them in before everyone can go
off and watch the the Michael Jordan
documentary so oh my god I'm so far down
questions - yeah let's see so so we
answered why he's based on over in
someone says have you ever considered
releasing that Jordan bobblehead is
merch for this from the show big travel
in there which is Michael Jordan so
definitely not someone says you
mentioned some behind-the-scenes people
that help you make these videos any
funny stories while working on an
episode or inside jokes that found their
way to an episode so I'll just cover
that up for a second which is like I was
MBA 1k which is one of our most popular
episodes Craig and I don't play to K
that much I played it a little bit and
so we brought in a couple of 2k experts
shout out Sean Mishra and Meech and we
talked to them and they
they gave us tons of inside jokes so
it's all about Ronnie 2k and like the
servers and everything people complain
about with that game so we always make
sure like we when we when we get like a
jersey number wrong that drives us crazy
so we really really try as silly as this
cartoon is to make sure we get
everything right and make sure that it's
like feels like you're the cartoon even
if we don't aren't fans that the team
feels like it was made by fans of a team
or fans of a game or something like that
cried you have a question you would
answer uh yeah do we have any regrets
about creating the characters as in
making some animals or some not or
anything else about creating them that's
from Damon Conway that's a good question
I have no regrets about making kyle
korver hawk in fact it's one of my
proudest moments are there any other
players that are animals
well Larry Bird's ambiguously a bird
sort of yeah no we did make chris bosh
dragon yeah that's why it's not a regret
but like it's just a cheap Joe
contracted like it's just a joke that it
kind of looks like a dinosaur and so
like I felt like he and Chris Bosh is
like an awesome dude it's I felt bad
about that and actually here this ties
into the first question which is you
know one of the reasons that we want to
try something new is that like you know
we make all these jokes about like NBA
players and like they're mostly nice
people and I kind of feel bad sometimes
when like you know it's like we think
it's time maybe to do some of the
original characters we don't have to
Craig doesn't care all right whatever
but I sometimes don't man we're
relatively tame compared to like the
actual cheeks they get from like sports
writers all the time we're just giving
them British accents and like making
random sometimes I feel bad
Craig I have one more question here will
do and that is oh and Queen Quinton says
why are the Celtics the Spurs of the
east and why are the Spurs a Tom B's
okay so the Spurs were initially the
white walkers because they just felt
like that team just would never die they
just always keep coming and every year
they're there no matter how old they
just this old boring tea
that just pushed forward they just felt
so perfectly the matched up with the the
white walkers
but then the Spurs started fading and we
saw the year before this the Celtics got
Kyrie they started to seem like Spurs II
like a bunch of like guys who played as
a team and were really well coached and
played selfless team basketball and
we're gonna be there for a while and boy
will be wrong about that because Kyrie
really screwed that up so we had to
address that and in that episode episode
7 of last season
why'd anything else oh what's that
we had blond hair because LeBron was
Jaime Lannister and so do you a was
Cersei Lannister yeah and you can think
about that implies obviously later we
made it so that Anthony Davis became
Cersei when they're up in the tower in
season six but we'll get there so yeah
so anyway guys a couple things before we
go first of all I want to say check out
the episode our new season premieres
Thursday at noon we're going to be here
tomorrow doing it the party we're going
to do season four which is our first
season with